la maison folio
milieu du 19e siècle les familles de
notables s'installe dans les hauts de
décembre à mars pour fuir la chaleur et
le paludisme
de nombreux villages d'altitude comme el
bour connaissent alors une période
d'essor la bourgeoisie fait construire
des maisons dites de changement d'ère
l'une des plus célèbres et la maison
folio contrairement à toutes les autres
demeures du village elle est construite
parallèlement à la rue ce n'est donc pas
sa façade que l'on aperçoit au premier
regard mais un kiosque hexagonal en bois
suivant les règles de l'emplacement
elle est précédée d'un jardin et masques
3 dépendance à l'arrière principalement
composés d'essences locales le luxuriant
jardin symbolise l'art de vivre créole
la maison une couverte d'une splendide
toiture de feuilles de métal posée en
écaille
elle est construite en bois dur du pays
réputée imputrescible tandis que les
dépendances abritant autrefois la
cuisine la salle à manger la salle de
bains et deux chambres d'amis sont en
pierre les meubles créole confectionnés
dans de somptueux bois de couleurs tout
comme les différents décors en bois
découpé reflète le soin particulier
apporté à la décoration de cette
résidence de villégiature
le kiosque abrite une petite pièce d'où
l'on bénéficie d'une vue imprenable sur
le piton des neiges
construit en même temps que la maison
c'est le premier des trois kiosques
delbourg protégé au titre des monuments
historiques